[موسيقى]
بصراحه بالمراحل الاولى اللي هي كانت اصعب
مرحله علي انا كنت عيد السجنز كل يوم اللي
بياخذها مع الاخصائي كنت عيد السجن اربع
مرات بالنهار جلسات النطق كنت ارجع اعيدهم
بحذافيرهم بنفس النهار
بالوقت اللي ما كنت عم بعطي انا جلسات
النطق ارجع اعيدها كن انا عم بعمل معه
نشاطات بقلب البيت فلما صار هو ردي لما
صار هو جاهز لحتى نعرضه لتجارب نكتشفوا شو
بحب بلشنا بقى نجرب جربنا كمبيوتر وجربنا
البروجرام وجربنا يعني ما في شيء ما جربنا
لك اكتشفنا انه محمود بارع بالبيانو بيقدر
يعبر عن حاله بالبيانو عن غضب وعن فرحه
يصورني بالبيت
عند خالو حمودي
ماذا لو طلب منا ان نتوقف لحظه ونلبس رداء
هذه الام او الاخت او ذلك الاب او الاخ
للحظه فقط ماذا لو ادركنا ان احد اطفالنا
مصاب بطيف توحد
جميع من تحدثنا اليهم لم يتمنوا تغيير
الادوار وانما طالبوا ممن هم حولهم او من
يصادفونهم في الشارع او في المتجر او
السينما او المدرسه في اي مكان تمنو ان
يمنح هؤلاء الماره اطفال التوحد القليل من
التفهم و شيئا من الحب
يؤلمني ان اراه يكبر وهو مازال بهذه
البراءه والطفوليه ربما لانني اخاف عليهم
من براءته ونظافه تفكيره وحبه المطلق
للبشر وعدم ادراك الشر الموجود في هذه
الدنيا
التاسيس كتير صعب مرحله كتير صعبه التاسيس
اللي هو انك تعلميه اول كلمه ينطقها اول
حرف يكتبه جدا مرحله صعبه من اصعب المراحل
وبنفس الوقت تحدي البلوغ
الهرمونات لما تلعب دور والسلوك قديش
بيتاثر كمان هذا تحدي جديد